the name across the stern is positive
identification everything we've seen
there confirms this is the Juneau 76
years after its sinking the wreckage of
the USS Juneau was discovered on the
ocean floor of the South Pacific the
Navy Cruiser was sunk by a Japanese
submarine during the Battle of
Guadalcanal on November 13th 1942 a
torpedo caused the Juno to go down in
less than a minute 687 people on board
the ship perished including all five of
the Sullivan brothers Joseph Francis
Albert Madison and George the brothers
had requested special permission to
serve together from the Secretary of the
Navy we've always been together since we
was born you might say and that's how we
want to go into the Navy the loss of the
brothers became a national story and
inspired the wartime film the fighting
Sullivans their story not only caught
the eyes of the American public but also
President Roosevelt he wrote a letter to
their parents saying in part I am sure
that we all take pride in the knowledge
that they fought side-by-side as one of
your sons wrote we will make a team
together that can't be beat there were a
number of tributes made in the Sullivans
honor
including the naming of a veteran's
Museum in Iowa and two Navy destroyers
the Juno was found by the research
vessel the petrel which is owned by
Microsoft co-founder Paul Allen so far
this venture has uncovered six other
World War two vessels
Robert craft headed the expedition it's
an age-old story and it's it's lasted
the decades each mission each ship that
we look for has a unique story and it
touches different people for different
reasons
you know the Sullivan brothers being
Irish we we found the Gino on st.
Patrick
well the incredible images and it's
great work they're doing just amazing
work their story was the one that
inspired Saving Private Ryan and the
fact they're mentioned in Saving Private
Ryan